the movie
is super violent did you have to fight
the mpaa
to get the r rating did you have to make
any changes
uh no we did not that's awesome
um did you have a much longer cut of the
film
um like how long was your first cut or
was it pretty close to what will be in
theaters
in hbo max the process of
creating something like this which is a
constant sort of balancing
and and evolving process
it's kind of like sculpting right so
there was
there were it got a bit longer and it
got a bit shorter and then i got a bit
longer it's just a constant balancing
you know we never stopped that process
of
getting the story right getting the
balance right and there's a lot of
ingredients in this movie so
it was really just about balancing up
those ingredients so they felt
correctly balanced and the pace of the
film
felt appropriate and really that's what
we were judging everything by so yeah
there's a few things that
when when by the wayside but
not a huge amount i mean some of it was
just
it's not like whole scenes were just
removed and there's a couple of things
that were off to the side
maybe one day and years to come we might
see the lighter day but
it was just you know it's just a
trimming process really
were the characters that came closest to
make to being in the movie
that were cut for whatever reason reign
for a while was was being talked about
and was in us
in a very very early version of the
script
but the way he was being uh
handled wasn't really moving the story
along and was
wildly expensive
so it was just that combination of like
well this is not really
nor was he it's not like it was raiden
or or you know liu kang or this
or sonja played not a really really key
classic
um so that's probably the only one
that's that's why they make these things
called sequels um
yeah uh who do you think is the
strongest character in the game
and who do you think is the strongest
character in the movie
when you mean strongest do you mean
hardest to beat or you mean
as a character well defined oh i would
say the hardest
hardest to beat i don't think
to me it doesn't really boil down the
character in the game it's who the human
you're playing
is um so it's hard for me to know
because i always get
destroyed by everyone so um
everyone beats me uh because i'm not
very well i'm not very good at it
um and then in the games i well i think
in the in the film yeah i guess you'd
probably have to say
to be scorpion or sub-zero but really if
you look at each of them
each of them would be pretty i think my
goal was always to try and make them as
even as possible
it was really the the fire
within their emotional part of their
character that that drove them one way
or the other
so you know the the intent
for revenge on his family
from scorpion is really the thing that
sort of
allows him to is that is the engine that
allows him to prevail
do you know the mortal kombat theme song
and can you sing it
yes and no
i don't i don't i don't blame you
i won't make you i've heard i've heard
that song
about 8 million times
so i know it
[Laughter]
who do you think has the most brutal
fatality
in the game uh i am curious what you
think about that
i don't really know him to be honest
it's just it's
in the eye of the beholder right so do
you have a favorite then
i i've always the reason i've always
loved
the kung lao hat stuff
and that's why that's why that's in
there
because to me it just hadn't
had a sort of a dynamic visual
inventiveness to it that's that tended
to transcend just
sort of out now violence it hadn't had
really good ideas and i like that aspect
of it
so i'm always looking for okay what's
the idea within it what what can
what are the things that the audience is
going to enjoy
just on a sort of a honor
just seeing a a character work something
out or
it's like the blood blade right so those
are the ideas that i feel
are the ones that audiences really
connect with because you're giving
they're like little gifts along the way
and you've got to keep giving those
gifts so there's multi layers of things
going on so there's character there's
story structure
it's obviously moving all that along but
then during that you've got to
provide these moments of surprise and
inventiveness and these little
so that was this sort of layering of of
what was going on in
on my mind all the time of how we
balance all that stuff out
sorry i off-roaded on your question
there but no it's my last thing because
i think i'm out of time um did you ever
discuss
doing like an after the credit scene at
the end of the credits or during the
credits was that ever something that
came up
yeah we talked about it but we never
wanted to do anything just for the sake
of doing what everyone else does
we really knew we had something original
here and you know no one at the studio
and no one but none of us ever felt like
oh we've got to do that it was just more
like
okay what what's right for our story and
what's right
to to make this movie
and so yeah i mean it was talked about
um bit ideas around but
it wasn't it never really once we locked
in and once that
once that ending locked in we
yeah i know exactly what you're talking
about okay i gotta go i'm just gonna say
congrats i hope it's a huge hit and you
get to make another one
thank you for your time thank you very
much mike nice chatting